dustin may who's now made 15 starts in
the majors
has a 2-6-4 era he's given up three or
fewer earned runs in all 15 starts
0-2 coming home and on three pitches a
strikeout for male 1
the plate is 17 inches wide dustin may's
two seam fastball moves about
19 inches so he can work it all the way
across the plate if he needs to
and now john gray will get this
dodger lineup that can be an
issue on nobody out up comes justin
turner
turner drills a lander to center that's
down for a hit
bets gets the wave hilliard's throw is
with runners at second and third this is
one of those when i say contacted bat
put the ball into play the slider that's
strike three oh my
goodness over the subaru strike zone you
know what
that's just a flat out miss by phil
cousy that was an
unquestioned strike and you're talking
about two outs
get off the field perhaps giving up one
run
the 3-2 blocks lifts one the other way
tapia drifting back
feels at the warning track makes the
catch that'll bring home corey seeger
heck of an ad back there for gavin watts
that turns into the sacrifice fly
and it's two nothing couple k's for the
big right-hander who faces the
eight-hitter dom nunez
into the wine the righty delivers nunez
strikes out swinging
third strikeout for may first out
of the third the ball in two strikes to
gray
and may with the pitch and it's hit in
the air down the right field line
and a diving try by mckinstry unable to
come up with it that's going to be a
base hit for john gray
may set at the belt takes a deep breath
comes back to the plate and gets a
strike at the knees
according to phil cousy and again
and and phil's going to throw somebody
out because again he's warning the
rocky's dugout but and somebody just got
tossed
it's bud black phil's had an awful night
bud
is hot three four and five coming up for
the dodgers in the shooting with justin
turner to lead it off
two on pitch turner hits a fly ball left
center field way back
and gone into the home run seats
three nothing dodgers i couldn't believe
it was making its way towards me
my first thought was not to try to reach
over the fence
luckily the nachos saved me and i can't
believe i i ended up with the ball
yeah the word on the street is that jt
actually sent me nachos
to replace the lasso and so shout out jt
and thank you
well again the rockies put a couple of
men on base
2-1 with one out for rymel tapia
that's not close and now the rockies
have the bases loaded with trevor story
coming up
and a live drive base hit to right
that'll get one home mckinstry
will fire it in and it's three to one
bases are still loaded now and because
of that the
dave roberts went to his bullpen brought
in victor gonzalez
and he goes left on left here with
charlie blackmon
charlie hits at the second not that hard
there's one and he'll get up the line
that was important another run scores
three to two
dodgers leading it three to two he's
here by
bets just crushed the spirit of the
rockies
one oh to bets and it's a ground ball to
short trevor story flips it to garrett
hampson at second for the force
and no damage done good job by tyler
kinley
seeger turner and muncie
down the left-field line tapia will not
get there it's a fair ball and it
bounces into the seats for a double
seeger has an 18-game hitting streak
against the rockies and he's in scoring
position to open the seven
so the dodgers with an important
insurance run
at second base with nobody out and
here's turner who's two for three
and an o2 pitch turner look out
[Applause]
trim that beard it's an all-one-two
pitch
the guy that's been hit more than
anybody in franchise history gets
plunked again
so rios winds up at second seeger at
third
now two down 3-2 dodgers and chris
taylor will bat for the first time
tonight
2-2 he got a beautiful pitch
on the outside corner at 95. job well
done with traffic
by michael gibbons 7-8-9
now in the dodger lineup mckinstry is
single in three tries tonight
kentree slices a drive back to left
center
zach mckinstry leaves the yard the
legend goes and it's 4-2
and you know what he loves playing the
game
he knows he fits on this team he's
become so popular to the point where
around second
he's given the dunk side
hey jansen in search of his third save
of the season alan trejo the pinch
hitter
told his story a little bit last night
he's an la native
from downey california
[Applause]
got him swinging there's 94. and there's
out number one
[Applause]
in line straight at home plate
everything behind it definitely looks
like the two seamer
that is strikeout number ten everybody
gets a free jumbo jack
tyne run up there one on one out ninth
inning garrett hampson
the leadoff man another 3-2
[Applause]
he struck him out
rocky's down to their last out he's had
the cutting action
at 89 90 91 this one at 90.
he's had some two seamers at 93.94
that one was well done
tapia stands in tying run with two gone
got him to chase the slider barnes lobs
it down to first and that's it